biola how are you doing i'm doing good
how you doing oh as they say this out
how you doing
i'm okay how have you handled this
pandemic how's it been for the family
because you
still have to be a mom you do and you
have to pick up puppy poop and you have
to mop floors and gotta cook
i'm handling it with wine
[Laughter]
wine but also with a huge level of grace
a huge level of forgiveness that you
know if
i i'm just embracing the fact that
things are
uh so different that i've allowed myself
to feel whatever i'm feeling that's what
it is even when i have
low grade depression it's very very
difficult
to not see your friends and family but
um
that's how i'm dealing with it yeah no i
hear how is everybody in the house
everybody else is okay
oh yeah my daughter's living her best
life she's is she
i don't listen i'm trying to harness
whatever she's got
[Laughter]
ma rainey such a pivotal character in
the music world but also
this was such a great play translating
it and bringing that heat like you and
denzel did with fences
to the screen what was that like and
what were those days
working with those great act those
gentlemen that you worked with
it was perfection you know it's the
thing about it is when you decide to be
an actor
the only way in you have is
you know you look at great movies or
whatever and then you actually become an
actor
and you have very few of those
experiences that you think you're going
to have
but every once in a while something
comes along and it's exactly what you
dreamed it would be
that everybody all great artists and
everyone from anne roth to denzel and
todd black to all the actors
to george c wolfe to branford marsalis
it's like it's like a most wonderful
stew
with the best ingredients and so
then you know the outcome the process
and the outcome is going to be
nothing less than than magnificent
that's
that's how i see it i just got to finish
the last part of this song
i got style oh everybody got style style
ain't nothing but keeping the same idea
from beginning to end
everybody got it yeah everybody can you
play that guy dude did you all didn't
know that chadwick was sick did you
when he was doing this did you have any
idea or
no no idea i mean you know
you know he was thin he was very thin
and he was very tired but can i just
tell you how many actors i've worked
with
who are very thin and very tired so
um there was no sense in that now
looking back you saw
you know his makeup artist and his and
his hairstylists who were praying over
him
and meditating over him and then you
wondered okay
maybe that's what he requires to work to
feel centered
but in hindsight all of it makes sense
now
um but that's the only part of it that
makes sense there is
there was nothing about chadwick
that was anything other than a life
force
anything other than bringing his utmost
to the
work the dedication the integrity
i i it's hard for me to see his life
tragically
it just really is i just he's just one
of those people you meet
every once in a lifetime that they focus
on
every single moment every single moment
yeah um you also playing mob
you had to do the padding and the sweat
and if people mention fences
they would you know they think of oh
there was that moment that that cry
that cry that moment and now with my
rainy it's the sweat
everybody will always remember the sweat
what was it like transforming into her
awesome was that your sweat or was that
hurt was that
well no that was a sweat from
my makeup artist but but but but also
because
george c wolfe set the play or set the
movie
in um the summer when originally the
play is set in the winter but he thought
that
the summer in the heat was would be its
own different character
oppressiveness you know yeah but also
when maharani is described
and there's very little information
about her but one of the things
uh they say that she always looked like
she was dripping in sweat
all the time so and that just added with
to the padding to the makeup that was
like grease paint
to you know the gold teeth i wanted to
create a character
on my own terms i did not want to filter
it through the white gaze
or through any kind of idea that people
would have
about someone who is larger black
singer woman usually those characters
are just
big big big and funny big black and
funny yeah
i wanted more than that i wanted
autonomy
the sooner you understand it and what
you say is what my state account
will be ready to go in 15 minutes we'll
be ready to go and madam says we're
ready to go and that's the way it go
around here
was denzel around a lot during the
shooting since he produced this
he was around a good bit yeah yeah he
knows when to step back
and he knows when to just step forward
and give uh just a
little you know direction here or there
but he's
very very respectful of other artists
and other artists meaning george c wolfe
who's the director
so um and i have to tell you there were
times i know
denzel was tearing up there were times
he just
loved it he was absolutely
you know um in the audience for it
real quick though we just found out
about natalie reed just the other day
and and she had passed away after a
cancer fight that no one knew about
uh and you posted about her any quick
thoughts
no i i like i said we're just gonna miss
her talent we're gonna dismiss
you know i'm just gonna say it i just
feel like every black artist out there
who contributes anything that's
wonderful and great you know which she
did
you know especially in comedy um
there they'll be miss they're soldiers
you know we'll miss our soldier you know
um
and and but i'm sure her family you know
i feel for them especially in the midst
of
colvin yes that's got to be hard so
god bless her